if you need to rent a car in Katmandu
these days you have to deliver relief
supplies to the earthquake zone in
exchange we're taking tents and sleeping
mats to the Sindhu pal Chuck district
for a local aid organization we drive
for three hours past houses that were
virtually destroyed by the quake but at
least the people along the major roads
are receiving aid suddenly our drive
comes to an end akka mudslide has
rendered the road impassable we have to
walk and experience what many aid
organizations have come up against most
of the villages are hard to reach on our
way we need a farmer who's giving her
dying cow a few drops of water
after a two-hour hike we arrived at last
the village teachers are distributing a
few sacks of rice it's the first relief
delivery since the earthquake it's not
enough to go around but at least it's
something other villages cannot even be
reached on foot that's one big problem
because roads have been blocked in same
some places and there are many villages
as such that there is no transportation
facilities people have been using
helicopters and other transportations
right now we need like organize
distribution and there have been like so
many villages that that does have not
been killed collected human casualties
and needs have not been analyzed it's
obvious what Kumari llama needs her
house is a pile of rubble when the
earthquake struck she was in the fields
with her family she's moved her kitchen
outside she's also storing rice and
other foods here a heavy rain shower can
easily ruin a week's rations will
compile and regard what get goods are we
can't live in our house we can't even go
into it of course we'll rebuild it but
that won't happen this year so first we
need a tent and of course drinking water
every day in order to survive here
kisame girls a casa
that's true of millions of people in
Nepal who have had nowhere to live since
the earthquake in this village at least
tweet as being harvested and thrashed it
wasn't buried in the rubble families who
got none of the relief supplies have
gathered at the community hall they're
furious the coordinator promises a new
delivery will be coming to the valley
honey look man if I give Anna it's time
to return to our car residents take us
down on a motor scooter when we arrived
we see large sacks of rice more sleeping
mats and tents being unloaded just what
the people up here indeed
it's not possible to get anything up
there how do you want to do that yes no
our people are here we will distribute
it to that to those people who have been
affected actually so and then the the
car half of the half of the materials
which is still in the vehicle we are we
are taking it off stencil where there is
much more effective how do you do that
it doesn't work after that we are moving
up there by motorcycle my motorcycle or
even by my people who will carry it so
we'll manage to do it how it is possible
even if it means people walking two
hours with a 30 kilo sack of rice on
their backs we set off again for
kathmandu on the way back we meet these
boys climbing around for our camera
makes a welcome change for them thoughts
about what the future may bring are far
away at least for now